Hi.
Hello.
My name is Layla.
Are you here with your parents or...
I'm with my mom.
Can you show me something?
No.
It's kind of boring having a tea or coffee by yourself...
...you need somebody to talk to.
Why are you wearing a hat?
How much money do you have?
Why is your hair white?
It's bit like of trees in autumn,...
...you can ask a tree why are your leaves brown?
Do you mean in the bank or...
Like where you put your money and stuff.
560 pounds a month, pension.
Wow.
If you do have that what would you do with it?
I would get a dog and get a house and swimming pool.
Where are your friends and where they are right now?
Some of my friends are abroad.
I was born in Jamaica, so a lot of my friends are there, you know.
I'm new in London.
Well I had hundreds and thousands of friends...
...but at the moment I got good enough Facebook friends.
Well maybe I can sit with you and have some coffee.
You like coffee?